[Music]
the ice is typically around five
centimeters when I skate on that sound
you hear is actually a combination of
two sound it's their sounds from crack
striking beneath me and the vibrations
within the ice plate itself it sounds
like it's something supersonic meet
Morten Einar hi I'm Morten Einar he's a
mathematician who enjoys riskier hobbies
than most I be skating on thin ice for
40 years when he's skating though he's
also listening consider the ice the
higher the pitch just about when the ice
is to break and that would be about
three centimeters the pitch is at the
highest see their supposedly highest
note on the soprano see wooden relies on
his knowledge as a mathematician to
calculate the thickness of the ice it's
flexibility and it's temperature many
people tend to freak out when they see a
skating on thin ice but I couldn't be
more calm because I know what I'm doing
sometimes the ice is perfectly clear and
I can see fish blow even a beaver and
also free divers swimming under the eyes
when Morten first started there wasn't
any physics or scientific information to
explain how thin ice skating is possible
he studied the ice for ten years every
winter to explain the phenomenon I
observed three things with a thin ice
one is that the ice bends and the
thinner it is the more advanced the arms
needs to be flexible to support you
second the first crack is a true warning
signals then I know the ice is spent and
when it gets even thinner more
first of all finally the ice gives
sonorous tone beautiful eerie tone which
immediately tells me how thick the ice
is
it's called the coincidence frequency
and it can be calculated mathematically
wooden has skated on over 1,800 bodies
of water in North America Norway and
Central and Eastern Europe I love
skating for the excitement and
challenges it brings it's an opportunity
for master nature to come together and
make it understandable for me I've been
skating most of my life and I always
look forward to next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this incredible glacier located in
Alaska is a popular tourist destination
but the best way to see it is from the
inside
mendenhall glacier is a 12 mile long
glacier in the Mendenhall Valley in
Alaska's Tongass National Forest the ice
caves are the glaciers surreal interior
access to see these icy walls are only
available to the truly adventurous to
see the ice caves requires a kayak trip
and ice climb over the glacier and once
you're inside the faith that the melting
walls around you won't give away but
this natural wonder is under threat the
glacier has been are treating incredibly
quickly in recent years due to warmer
temperatures and rising sea levels it
has receded by almost 2 miles since 1958
but what remains is an utterly
breathtaking Fantasyland
[Music]
[Music]
think of being in a freezer and then
somebody puts your face directly into a
big pile of wet ice cubes that's what it
feels like I'm speaking to Lisa Kelly
she's a scuba diver with National
Geographic and she leads expeditions in
Antarctica and the arctic temperatures
and Arctic waters typically range
between 25 and 35 degrees Fahrenheit
because the waters are so cold divers
have to use special gear this includes
use of a dry suit
these suits actually keep divers dry
when they're underwater I like to call
it a self-induced state of hypothermia
really because even though you're dry
you're still going to get cold and that
is such a shock on people's system
unfortunately there have been deaths due
to cardiac incident because of that
aside from the cold there are other
things that divers need to be on the
lookout for walrus polar bears animals
like killer whales reverberate sound we
call it singing it sounds like a gunshot
underwater it can go right through you
but Lisa Kelly says that diving in the
Antarctic and the Arctic is an
unparalleled experience and it starts on
the boat that initial feeling when you
fall back in the water it's just the
sound of you breathing through your
regulator it suddenly becomes your own
little world all of a sudden all these
amazing colors start to pop out and it
really is a whole other universe and in
Antarctica you're there in a place where
possibly nobody has ever died before
[Music]
[Music]
these organisms are beautiful and iconic
there are certain types that are present
nowhere else on earth so it's very
important to study them
my name is drew Laura and I'm the
principal investigator on science under
the ice science under the ice is what
we've been calling our project where
we've been studying the resilience of
organisms the seafloor organisms to
climate related changes and we do
science under the ice literally by scuba
diving under frozen ocean in Antarctica
the most recent trip was to explorers
Cove new harbour which is in the rough
sea Antarctica
our team was science scientists and
technicians and of those seven of them
were scientific divers that dived
underneath the ice
we are about to commence our dive
operations for the morning slash
afternoon on this trip we went diving
underneath the ice to deploy large-scale
experiment involving incubation chambers
that we deploy to the seafloor we also
surveyed the fauna using standard survey
techniques and we collect the organisms
for isotopic analysis so we can
reconstruct the food webs and how
they've changed since our previous trips
the water is negative two degrees
Celsius it's very very cold and we have
to dive through ten feet of sea ice in
order to access our study sites thumbing
in under the ice is quite surreal it's
like diving into I light because the
light is dim it's almost in some ways
like diving in outer space because of
the vistas that you get towards the
underside of the ice with a light coming
through and the clarity of the water is
unbelievable it's almost like you're
floating in air
I think documenting what is down there
now and how it's changing over time is
really important this year all of us
were struck by just how quickly things
can change and it shows just how there
is essentially climate models that are
predicting changes in sea ice conditions
/ under the ice is pretty extreme it's
hard to keep the heat up at the hunt
because the the Sigma stoves are not
working that well that being said the
divers
under the ice because of the beauty and
the unique experience that it provides
[Music]
[Music]
once you start climbing then the biggest
hazard is avoiding all those big icicles
they're huge like the size of a family
car those daggers are really not
attached that well to the rock and
sometimes it takes just a small kick and
they just collapse and fall down
my name is clément primero I'm an ice
climber and adventurer my climbing has
taken me to so many different places all
over the world
then how come Falls came into the radar
and it just changed everything I mean
it's the steepest ice you can find
anywhere
once you're there and you're walking
towards the ice phone you just get this
feeling how big it is I mean it's huge
and it's steep to have overhanging eyes
it's really rare usually ice climbs are
formed vertically we didn't see
overhanging eyes before hunting Falls
I do believe life starts when you step
out of the comfort zone climbing forces
you to go outside of your comfort zone
it forces you to look out for this
fragile line between having good time
and not risking too much
ferrets present a lot but once I'm there
and once I start to work on the root the
fur just goes away there's no more fear
it's just about learning and having good
time